hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round 10 of the
2018 candidates tournament this time
between Sharma media of and Fabiano
Caruana
and I know you all enjoyed that game
Kramnik versus Aragon and it's not like
every every game can be like that that's
like that's like very rare to see but
for some reason when chronic plays in
the candidates see you can see at every
game
and here this game had had its
opportunities of also becoming a really
violent and crazy game but you'll just
have to see what happens and I didn't
get to show any photos in the kramnik
Aragon game so here I do have one here
is RN and pondering over the position
and the kramnik blurry on the left
probably going all pirate and Nikki for
disturbing his brilliant thought process
but here we have from this game mama de
aragón the left Fabiano on the right and
if anyone knows the name of the person
I'm making the first move for mommy
Gerald do share in the comments here we
have another photo of media of a nice
close-up and here we have a nice
close-up of Fabiano so now I think we're
all set let's let's see the game so this
is basically a clash of leaders Fabiano
only half a point in front of mama dro
and if mommy DRF can win this game it
would be a tremendous opportunity for
him to do maybe even win the candidates
who knows Andy Fabiana wins this game
then he I mean he would be a whole point
and a half in front of everyone else so
he could actually afford to even lose
the game and still win the candidates
that would be insane
so d4 by mommy they are off we have
Knight to f6 c4 and c6 Knight to f3 the
antonyms oh variation now d5 we
transpose again into the Queens gambit
declined and now G 3d captures on c4
Bishop to g2
so the Catalan opening Knight to c6 and
we have castles rook to b8
III and Bishop to e7 and it was in this
position that usually a6 is played but
here a Fabiano spent
six and a half minutes for Bishop to e7
so obviously I mean Bishop to e7 is
definitely home preparation move you
don't you don't do a move like this over
the board but it seems Fabiano like
Botvinnik likes to spend some time you
know really and making sure that it's
the correct move even though he prepared
it at home here we have Knight f2 d2
some seven minutes were spent by this by
momma Dee Arif so he definitely wasn't
expecting Bishop to e7 and here he five
so this move was played like maybe in
twenty seconds so you can see that
Bishop three seven is a prepared
variation Fabiana was just checking it
Bishop captures on c6 we have B captures
on c6 tripling blacks pawns and now D
captures on e5 Knight to g4 Knight
captures on c4 and here Bishop to e6
again I prepared move as of course you'd
expect Queen captures on d1 and here
Knight B to d2 it took it took mom idea
of some I think some 10 minutes to find
this move and here we have h5 also a
prepared move by Fabiano so I think all
of this was found over the board and
here Mahmoud Arab does have to do
something about this night in the game
f3 was played but it's interesting what
happens if h3 is played if h3 is played
then black does have this option of
playing Queen to d3 and after pawn
captures Knight pawn captures on g4 and
here black has this very interesting
threat of Queen to h7 followed by Queen
to h1 checkmate here white would have to
block this with E 4 but then white black
would simply win back the piece Bishop
captures on c4 Knight captures and now
Queen captures on e4 threatening again
checkmate on h1 and there's really no
good way to block this f3 and now Bishop
to c5 check you have to block with rook
but now again Queen to h7 a threatening
Queen to h1 checkmate and after we try
to escape this all leads to annihilation
King the to Bishop captures on f2 and
it's all over
captures captures there is nothing
for whites to hope for here as there is
also a very strong past born on f3
so after this h5 move shock doesn't go
for h3 he actually goes for f3 here
Queen to d3 again and it's it's not a
peace sacrifice yes mama D ro does play
F captors and g3 but now you don't you
don't really have the same option of of
capturing with this as Queen to h7
doesn't really threaten Queen to h1 as
there's a pawn now on h2 and you don't
really gain anything by playing Bishop
captures attacking the Queen as after
Queen to a4 you simply move the Queen
threat and Queen captures on c6 would
check the ring maneuver the Queen and
after h4 Queen captures with check King
moves now comes rock to f4 and after for
example H captures and g3 you capture
the bishop pawn captures on h2 with
check King to h1 and the King is
actually perfectly safe on each one
there is no continuation here for black
denies the knight is covering the f1
square nicely so after this F captures
on g4 sorry F capture Sun G 4 I have
Fabiana played Bishop characters on c4
grabbing back the piece we have Knight
captures Queen captures on c4 and the G
captures on h5 simply winning back that
pawn and here it took Fabiano a long
time to figure out what to do here G
captures on each v is the best move you
think maybe rook to f4 seems like an
improvement in the position why not
simply gain a temple on the Queen kick
it off of this active Square and only
then capture well because after Queen to
e6 the e6 square is much more active
Square for the Queen and the rook was
actually pretty useful on f1 and now G
captures on h5 Queen captures on e5
Queen to c2
we simply capture on h5 again you have
you have a pretty strong grip on the
position you already cleared all of the
pawns white head and it's not that white
is worse here or anything maybe just
giving black too much so after this
Queen captures on c4 and G characters on
h5 Fabiano played Queen to e6
and it took him some 23 minutes to
decide on this move he could go rook to
b5 immediately with the idea of
capturing here and capturing here
doubling rooks on the H file but then
white has this annoying b3 move kicking
away or Queen and after our Queen moves
for example attacking the rook and I
want now Queen to d4 forcing you to
trade Queens and after captures captures
rook captures on h5 it's again a better
position for white the pawn structure is
better it's a clean pawn up so after
this Queen to a6 Queen to b6 which took
for me around 23 minutes it took smomid
era of 33 minutes for his next move and
he plays Queen to f3 again there were
some ideas possible here for example you
could try and simply develop with b3
Queen captures on e5 now rook to be one
Queen captures on h5 and after Queen to
c2 your position is again okay as white
white is even better here but again you
kind of don't want to give up these two
points too quickly so black and set up
the pieces however he wants to so Queen
to f3 here Mahmoud are always preparing
Queen to a5 he wants to trade Queens as
if anything he's running into fabiana's
preparation it's not the other way
around
so rock to b5 and Queen to f5 now
offering a trade of Queens rook captures
only five Queen captures rook captures
and rook to f5 and here it took Fabiano
12 minutes and after 12 minutes he
decided to go for rook to d6 and I
caught a glimpse of the live coverage
here by Gustafson and sweet ler and
there was a crazy engine line here that
they discussed that was actually rook to
f6 and rook to f6 is an interesting move
because why do you allow rook to a 5 if
rook to a5 going for the pawn here
what's your look actually doing on f6
but that's the idea now rook to d6 is a
lot stronger than rook to d6 immediately
like Fabiano played now if you capture
on a 7 you get rook captures on h5 and
here it's a very double-edged position
but black black definitely has the upper
hand is he's a lot more active and
here you would have to actually play b4
but you would only see that if you
actually decided to develop with b3 and
now you'll get rook to d1 this is what
check King knows and now Rock the c5
because of this rook to c5 you had to
play b4 and give up this b4 point to the
bishop because now after you move the
bishop try and exchange rooks now you
get rook to d2 check and you simply lose
the piece here so a lot of interesting
things possible after rook to f6 but ok
5e goes for route to d6 and now we have
King to g2 again you can't really
develop and the rook is very useful on
d6 is not allowing the bishop to develop
the d2 it's a it's really hard for black
for white to develop and it's really
interesting how mama D ro pulls it off
here rook to d1 and now we have b3 g6
now it's interesting Bishop to e3 does
seem like a crushing move but it
actually gives nothing after rook to f1
I simply have to exchange all the pieces
row capture screen captures and after
this it's again white who's better
because blacks pawn structure is
somewhat corrupted here by the CC pawns
but okay after be three g6 and now we
have a rook to e5 c5 now pawn captures
pawn captures and now e4 Rock to h7 here
Fabiano goes for rook to f7 followed by
a rope to f1 we have h for now and h4 is
the move that was needed to get out this
mess
rook to f7 now comes King to h3 you
still can't move this Bishop anywhere or
play something like Bishop here
otherwise you get rook rook check and
then you lose the bishop
so first King to h3 not allowing any
checks now comes Luke f7 to f1 now
threatening to win the bishop and now
better to g5 this was the idea now you
get rook captures on a1 and rook
captures on e7 here Mahmoud Arif
sacrifices the exchange but he will win
a lot of points for it
so King to f8 now rook captures on c7
rook captures on e2 and now
to e7 check King to g8 now first rope to
FA I roped the CH check King to g8 of
course you can go to f7 then rock here
wins the rock on f1 so Bishop captures
on c5 rook to e2 and now II five would
the idea of course if you capture simply
Bishop pins the rook
so after this if I move rook to d1 we
have rook to e8 defending the pawn as
now there is no longer the the
possibility of pinning the rook as the
rock is on d1 rope to d5 and now Bishop
to d6 an interesting move simply because
the rook captures doesn't really win the
game white won't recapture immediately
first rook to e7 check and then after
the King moves then he captures and then
white is actually two points up winning
this game
so after Bishop d6 rook to e3 we have
rookie 7 check King g8 rukia checking f7
rookie 7 check repeating a couple of
moves to reach move 40 King to g8 and
now before this is move 40 so mama D ro
is still interesting maybe to even win
this game so you know why not he is now
in the exchange but he is up to pawns
and with this Bishop protecting these
points so nicely it's very unlikely for
for Fabiano to be able to do anything
with his rooks Rock d2 d3 now attacking
the g3 pawn we have King to g4 rook
captures King a for Rupe to f3 check
King to e4 rook to e3 check King to a 4
look again here King to g5 and now rook
to f7 and here we have e 6 rook to d5
check King captures on g6 and now rook
captures on the 6 of course now if a
pawn captures on f7 is impossible the
pawn is pinned
rook captures on f7 and now rook
captures on e6 rook to f6 and now rook
to e4 of course you don't want to
exchange rook here then white would be
winning
so rook to e4 simply wouldn't attack on
the h4 pawn as well as the b4 pawn
b5 rook captures rook to a6 and now rook
to h7
be six now and rock to g7 check it would
be an excellent a mistake for Fabiano to
blunder here with pawn captures pawn
because then rook to e8 would be
checkmate unfortunately
so after b6 Brooke to g7 check King
moves now a couple of more chicks pawn
captures on b6 and after rook captures
here was Czech rook to f6 blocking and
only the naked Kings around the board of
course this is now a draw so a decent
game you know the game could have taken
any any wrong turn and the game would
simply explode into into a complete mess
especially if one of these players was a
lot emir Kramnik but you know an
excellent game by two leaders of the
tournament and you know better to better
to draw the game then to allow one or
another to take complete control of the
tournament now everything is still open
so even my media of still still does
have excellent chances of winning the
candidates so this was a round ten and
before I forget I did prepare the
standings after this around 10 so here
we have Khurana still in first place
with still with six and a half points
out of ten Mahmud II arrived in second
with six then Greece shook with five and
a half so he's definitely still in the
game of winning the candidates Kuryakin
with five ding liver and n15 Kramnik
with four and a half with today's win
over Aragon then so and then Aragon
alone in last place this is truly a
standings you know no one you know when
the tournament started no one thought
this could this could actually be what
the standings looked like at around 10
but it is how it is and it's interesting
you know it's I'm definitely interested
in in chrome Nexus game against Caruana
he will have the black pieces against
Fabiano and if he continues playing like
this maybe he can still do some real
damage in this tournament if he beats
Fabiana with the black pieces then he
goes up to five and a half
Fabiano stays in six and a half and then
really
anything is possible and then probably
anyone could win this tournament but
that's just the joy of enjoying the
candidates we'll just have to wait and
see so yeah that's it I do hope you
enjoyed it it was an excellent game like
I said feel free to comment any anything
if you've seen the live coverage
I do appreciate anything as I do I do
want to show you this game but I also
want to learn something so I feel free
to do so and if you know who the
gentleman was that made the first move
for my media also do share and once
again I would like to thank Nikki for
her photos from the candidates as usual
if you're interested in photography
especially in chess photography all of
the links to her social media will be in
the description below so feel free to
follow her work and yeah that's it thank
you for watching as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and I
will see you soon thank you